what's up everybody i'm corbin blue
hi i'm monique coleman and you may know
us from high school musical taylor
mckessie
will you please be my date to the senior
prom i'd be honored but now we are
trading musicals for mistletoe in our
lifetime holiday movie christmas dance
reunion premiering december 3rd so to
celebrate we are going to interview each
other for e.t let's do it
i am having the time of my life no
matter how long you're away from
something you can always come back to it
what if we brought it back let's have
one last christmas dance all right so
kick it off obviously it has been
13 years since we shared the screen in
high school musical how did it feel for
you
for us to just
kick it off again and get back on screen
together i obviously knew that i would
love like hanging out with you like in
the work sense of just like oh yeah
we're going to be on set together but i
didn't process what it would be like to
get to work with you again like actually
as an artist and that was really
invigorating to me i love that it's
funny
i wasn't surprised
oh wow main thing for me it was that i
just felt reassured and so
comfortable in knowing like what i felt
like it was gonna be that's that's
exactly how it went i'm gonna be honest
about why that means a lot it means a
lot because because dancing was such a
central
part of this film but
you just be out here on broadway
you know just like doing the splits
doing the kicks and tapping
and
this is going to be like normal you're
like but it's true i was worried that
i'd be a little bit intimidated and i
wanted to make sure i was and i was like
i just want to make sure that i'm able
to like keep up and that these you know
at the time 39 year old knees we're not
gonna like
betray the story i've always just looked
at you and just admired how incredible
of a performer you are and you give 120
every single time and i do as well it's
just that my hundred and twenty is just
a little less sometimes
not even first of all i love you for
saying that thank you but even like i
what you're saying right now funny
enough actually makes me think back to
our high school musical days and even
just the moment we had to jump in the
pool at the end of the second movie and
your fear
and just me actually being the one to
jump in with you and hold your hand and
yeah i'm like it's gonna be fine we're
gonna be great like if it's that exact
same mentality whatever that fear that
you had it's gonna be great speaking of
high school musical um is there anything
that you would go back and tell your
younger self from an artistic
perspective
i feel like i was always on the right
path but i think it's more from a
business perspective
uh just even
financially even just
knowing how to
manage everything and as far as trusting
other people too i think that was where
you know
that's where problems came in i didn't
have to learn that until
later
that um
all of a sudden you know now in my in my
my early 20s you know i've where again
i've been i've i've been working since i
was two years old and all of a sudden
now it's like oh wait a minute how does
all this work and just and just to
clarify you know i've never been a big
spender i've never been you know oh yeah
person that i like i
as far as like brand name i couldn't
care less like
i have my i have my my big purchases in
my life you know as far as like a house
and a car and like that kind of stuff
but i've never been crazy with my money
so that's why it's thank god you know
i've been in a place that i was like
strapped all right now to to flip the
script on you what would be something
you would tell yourself don't take
yourself seriously but take your
business seriously don't be naive unlike
you i actually did
i did get broke
like i did
um but it was for beautiful reasons um
you know this but i after high school
musical i started a non-profit and i
ended up becoming the first ever united
nations youth champion and i funded a
global trip around the world to meet
young people and understand what they
experienced and faced in globally and
that feels that is very altruistic
that's really noble and and i don't
regret a single moment of it but it also
really uh became a very different it
caused me to start to have a very
difficult financial situation and so it
but that didn't have to happen had i
understood certain things about
you know
money making money for instance because
i never did anything wrong it's just
that i didn't do things right and that
is what i wish that i would have known
and that is what i'm passionate about
telling you know other young people you
don't have to have partied and you know
lost your money um buying handbags and
luxury cars or you know wigs
if you're me
but you actually can your heart can be
the reason you know the house that you
want to buy your mama the you know the
people that that you that you're taking
care of before you've actually
you know developed a sense of
sustainability i think this will get so
perfectly
i i i feel like you are such a
motivational person and i will tell you
i mean you know this and for those of
you out there who don't know she is we
call her mopra and she is always being
our
motivator mo
and our our inspiration and i just want
to know what
motivates you what inspires you we so
often are asked questions about high
school musical are there any memories or
stories or things like that and you
actually just brought up one that i
can't believe i've never shared which is
that i believe we were shooting uh stick
to the status quo
and i was sitting next to to kenny
because that was like my favorite place
to sit uh in video village
and
uh i remember watching like you guys
were just like standing on your heads
and just like
just doing incredible things with your
bodies and i could see you all start to
get tired and i remember walking over
like being like like not like i got it
but like at 25 years old like i thought
i knew everything and i came over and i
like gave you guys like a halftime
speech and nobody cared and i started to
walk away and all i heard was you go
thanks mopra
and i was just like
i've never shared that story and it you
know didn't really occur to me until you
just said it just now the truth is i
think i'm motivated by
my inner child i felt very lonely as a
kid that's just the truth i had a very
vibrant personality but my inner world
was very troubled i had i just was like
incredibly insecure and i just didn't
feel like i was enough and i now i think
i'm motivated by letting people know
that they are enough and also watching
you know watching you all grow up you
know we do have a kind of significant
age difference and so when we started in
high school musical i was a little older
with a bunch of teenagers that were more
confident than me i'm motivated by the
possibility that my life could have
meaning to someone else who may or may
not have
taken that chance if they weren't just
told that they can't
pay it forward that's amazing this is
kind of a random question i'm just
totally curious if you were not an actor
though
and you were not a performer what would
you do
[Music]
okay
so
um
there i have two answers to this i
actually was accepted into stanford for
psychology
i'm now okay i'm sorry stop pause
you got accepted into stanford i did for
psychology and that was the same year
that i booked high school musical and it
was because of the success of high
school musical that we kept going and we
shot these other movies and we went and
toured that i i never went i'm so glad i
asked this question because i had no
idea that's incredible that's amazing so
that's one half of the question then the
other half is i was on broadway i was
literally in the middle of doing a
broadway show um which dream come true
and i would burn
out i just want a break i just need
something else i need something
different um and i found myself so we
were i was in new york and the apartment
that we were staying at
had a balcony and on the other side
there was a building that was going up
and every day i would look at the crane
and look at the guy inside the crane and
i'll go man i just want to be in there
right now and so that kind of led me to
go you know what in in my down time in
hiatus
um why don't i go do something else and
that was where i i know you know this
journey but um sasha and i my wife and i
were in the middle of renovating our
home and i'm actually working on it
myself
um and i'm working towards getting my
contractors licensed what would you be
doing if you weren't acting yes very
briefly i would
likely be a kindergarten teacher
of course you would of course you would
or i'd be a personal trainer like i'd be
like a fitness guru of some sort i love
this again yes so different so
and yet so perfect but both in a
teaching mentoring
uh position by the way true
true
[Laughter]
that is from our first christmas dance
together
wow was there a scene that you just
loved filming more than any others in
the film it was such a special
set such a special movie
um not only you and i getting to work
with each other on screen again but then
also to have sasha also on set all three
of us those dynamics any time that the
three of us were on set together
was
was surreal and special and magical and
exciting it was just like every time i
look like i can't believe this is
actually happening but if there's
something different um i'll i'll say it
was it was my tap because it was the
first time that i got to to tap on
screen it wasn't even supposed to be a
part of the movie you know it was yeah
and it was so beautiful to watch too
like that was the moment that like sasha
and i were just like behind the monitor
just like all teary-eyed like this is
it was iconic and magical and
yeah it felt like what it felt like one
of those moments of like gene kelly in a
movie where you're just like what in the
world what is this like all that talent
just like exists in your body all the
time it's amazing i know that you and
sasha
have done like a handful of films
together over the years but this was
very unique because we were all three
together
and here i am as your love interest here
she is the love of your life
what was that like for you
i was just enveloped in love and i gotta
say i i i'm really i'm so lucky uh and
and
the reason why
that it works so well is because sasha
and i's relationship is so strong here
you have the two of us
having to play on screen lovers and yeah
and you know this
no no one no one is more excited about
that relationship that on-screen
chemistry than sasha that's like she's
the constantly the one like in the same
way in the movie that she her character
is championing for us to get together um
she's that she's the same way
camera too i'm just so lucky to have to
have a wife that not only supports what
i do and lifts what i do i also get to
like do it with her
oh my gosh i'm no i know
like it's it's such a crazy dynamic to
have to have that there i want to try to
save the winter early together but if we
have to let the winter league go i don't
want to let you go i don't want to
either no obviously when the trailer for
this movie came out like the high school
musical fans just like
i mean they're always there but it was
just so incredible to see how
just much support we still have and
there's so many people that were just
like i don't care this is they're
they're still chad and taylor i know
that they see chad and taylor but my
hope is that lucy and barrett win their
hearts and i just want to know from you
you know what do you hope that the high
school musical fans
are able to take away when they see this
movie well i think you just said it
wonderfully and i'm gonna take that one
step further i know that
there is an element of this movie that
will
satisfy those who didn't meet chad and
taylor
come to a full fruit you know come to
full fruition with their relationship
but i hope that they see not only lucy
and barrett but that they see corbin and
monique
so
i also think to have you know that a a
continuing
on-screen couple um
of color
is
so needed you don't get to see that many
bipap uh
couples that that do continue on that
relationship that's very true because
you do you have emma stone and ryan
gosling and leo and kade and bradley
cooper and jennifer lawrence you know
they've done like four movies together
or something and you're very right about
that this is this is very unique what a
beautiful opportunity to
dismantle that stereotype or dismantle
this idea that we are just one thing you
know so seeing as it has been 15 years
now can you see a framework of
revisiting taylor do you
think that there is a way for us to
maybe ever revisit our characters but in
a more winky sense to it i love taylor
and i feel like i learned a lot from
taylor
i can't imagine what that story would be
like but i i can't say that i can't say
that it's not possible you never know
what about you i i feel exactly the same
way um you know obviously when it comes
to the relationships of
all of us in the cast
we went through the life-changing time
together obviously that created these
very strong rooted relationships um that
anytime i see
anyone anybody it's just like love it's
just a love fest so getting a chance to
work together again would be wonderful
did i tell you the idea that i had
though that i would want andrew uh would
be
to do a live at the hollywood bowl
a one night only
one night only oh it's not like 20 years
like like five years from now like kenny
ortega like directing a live with an
orchestra and all of us like just with a
microphone with our scripts and just
like just to like bring all three movies
together in some like one night only way
i really feel like people would fly from
every part of the world to be a part of
something like this and that is actually
something interesting that i would
do and like to see so
we can get that as
well
so whoever wants to call us
corbin this was really fun yeah
seriously i don't actually learn things
it's like i i don't know how we've been
friends for
literally 15 years and somehow in this
conversation
i learned more about you than i've known
than i even knew that that could be so
true that's really cool
[Music]
you